An oiled-up interview with a childhood crush,
stowing away in a stranger’s trunk and wrestling
a judo champion at a fancy party.
Over the years the shameless Impractical Jokers
have come up with some truly unforgettable gags.
For Murr's punishment for losing "In Poor
Taste Buds", he got what initially seems like
a pretty enjoyable task: being a culinary
expert and critic tasting and rating food
in front of a class.
However, the guys soon let him in on the twist:
his mouth is going to be injected with as
much Novocaine as is clinically allowed just
before going on stage, meaning he won't be
able to taste anything or speak properly.
As soon as the dentist injects the Novocaine,
its effect is noticeable on Murr.
“I know most people get spaghetti and meatballs
in a bolognese sauce.
Most people get spaghetti and meatballs in
a bolognese sauce.”
He struggles to pronounce most words, especially
those with the letters ‘b’, ‘p’, ‘s’,
and ‘f’.
Taking advantage of this, the guys make him
repeat alliterated sentences using those letters
constantly.
“Braised beef."
"Is brilliant."
"Is…
Braised pffft.
Braised beef is pfftt.”
Soon, Murr has to start eating and drinking
the food, which becomes quite the ordeal,
since he can't feel anything that his mouth
is doing.
The combination of Murr's hilarious struggles
with completing sentences, along with the
great audience reaction, make "In Poor Taste
Buds" one of Murr's top pranks of all time.
The guys in "Impractical Jokers" kick off
Season 2 with a bang with the episode "Elephant
in the Room."
The first challenge is the "Holy Molar" challenge,
which sees the guys pretending to be dentists
and interacting with patients, of course having
to do whatever they are told.
For example, Q informs his patient he has
an embarrassing story about sexually transmitted
infections and Atlantic City before using
the suction wand on his face.
“Tell him that's not your worst story about
crabs."
"That's not my worst story involving crab
in Atlantic City if you know what I mean.”
Sal's up next, and he has to practically invert
his patient on the dental chair before running
out of the room and leaving him hanging upside
down for several minutes.
“Keep the chair moving the whole time buddy.
Don't stop.”
Joe starts telling his patient about the various
dental tools at his disposal, including shoe
horns and dubiously named pliers.
“In the industry, we call this the bi-lateral
hammer ray rammer.”
The best performance is from Murr, who simply
spins and twirls around the room on the wheeled chair.
For the "Strip High Five" prank, Murr and
Joe have to deal with an ultra-rare double
punishment when both of them tie for last
after three challenges.
The two have to stand in the middle of Union
Square and play a game of strip high five.
The idea is that each of them has to try and
get strangers to high-five them.
For every stranger who refuses to high-five
them, they have to remove an article of clothing.
Both of the guys have some success at first,
as most people are pretty friendly.
As soon as they start losing more clothes,
people are more reluctant to have anything
to do with them.
“Sir high-five."
"Nope?
F–k!”
Pretty soon, the guys attract a crowd of onlookers,
and they both get down to their underwear.
Joe is successful in getting a high five in
his underwear, but Murr is not so lucky.
“Please give me a high five.
Oh no!
Please.
Yeah!
Yeah!”
And he ends up getting his underwear pulled
down by Joe in the middle of the street.
Joe then grabs the rest of Murr's clothes
and dashes off, leaving him standing there
barely able to cover himself, looking deeply,
deeply ashamed.
It was, as Q called it,
“The most public of humiliations”
Season 1 of "Impractical Jokers" has some
of the series' best moments, and the "That
Looks Delicious!"
prank from the episode titled "Out of TP"
is no exception.
For this challenge, the guys find themselves
at a buffet restaurant.
Unfortunately for them, they aren't allowed
to purchase any of the food.
Instead, they have to grab food from the plates
of unsuspecting diners, and whoever ends with
the least amount of food on their plate loses.
Q goes first, but he almost immediately forfeits
after no one gives him the time of day.
“Hi.
How are you?
You seem very nice.
I’m not.
Okay.”
Murr gets caught instantly trying to grab
some corn, and another guy notices him grabbing
a wing, though he doesn't say anything.
He steals another woman's okra, and his plate
ends up weighing a respectable 1 lb, 4 oz
at the end.
Sal immediately starts grabbing food from
patrons left and right, but he only comes
up with 1 lb total.
“The amount of dirty looks that are getting
thrown your way.
There’s mayhem going on out here.
This is complete mayhem.”
Joe is the final contestant, and he starts
scatting while grabbing food from a few female patrons.
One of them alerts her husband, who decides
to test Joe out and see if he tries it with him.
When Joe does, the guy smacks his macaroni
spoon away from him.
Joe ends up following him to the table and
grabs some fried chicken after a brief tong
fight, but his plate still weighs under a
pound and he loses along with Q.
The best "Impractical Jokers" punishments
are brutally public, and the one from "Below
the Belt" is an all-time classic.
Murr is the loser of the episode, so he has
to endure the punishment.
His task is to deliver a PowerPoint lecture
on the science behind climate change, which
Murr claims he can do in his sleep.
However, while Murr is giving the speech,
the guys will have access to his lower body
via a hollow table he is standing in front
of.
The audience can't see the guys under the
table, and they immediately start making Murr's
presentation as difficult as possible.
Sal begins by waxing one of Murr's legs while
he's speaking, making Murr grimace and squirm.
“Still allows.
AHA!"
Next up is Q, who sprays Murr's pants with
a water bottle to make it look like he wet
himself.
He then has to step on a mouse trap and walk
around wearing high-heeled shoes, confusing
the audience immensely.
But that wasn’t even the most embarrassing
part of the prank.
“What?
"Hi."
The coup de grace is when Joe turns Murr's
slacks into short shorts, again making him
parade around in front of a bewildered and
amused audience.
As punishment for losing the "Junk in the
Trunk" challenges, Sal had one of his most
high-energy moments on the show.
The gag is that the guys are at a local car
rental agency and Sal has to hide in the trunk
of one of the vehicles.
He's supposed to ride along in the trunk until
the person needs to open it, at which point
they'll see him and be shocked.
The prank gets off to a seemingly rocky start
when the renters take the car on a much longer
trip than expected.
Sal rattles around in the trunk while the
woman drives around, smacking his head several times.
“I just went flying.
Ohh.
Speed bumps coming up.
Oh god no no no.”
Eventually, the car stops, and a woman gets
out and opens the trunk.
“Hi, I’m sorry.”
Finally, when it seems like the woman is truly
upset, Joe reveals the truth: It's actually
his friend Melissa, who knew about Sal in
the trunk the whole time.
Her getting upset was all an act and Sal bought
it, hook, line, and sinker.
“Where are we?
Around the corner.
Yeah, we like went around the corner.
Just went around the block.
Oh god.”
One of the funniest recurring pranks on "Impractical
Jokers" is the "Did I Deserve That?"
challenge.
For these challenges, the guys are working
as cashiers behind a store counter when an
irate customer barges in and throws water
at their faces while they are in the middle
of a transaction.
The guys then have to sell whatever excuse
they are told to get the customer to say they
did not deserve it.
“What did we do wrong?
We’re gonna find out!
And no matter how bad it is, we’ve gotta
defend it.”
The first time the guys did the challenge
was during the episode "The Blunder Years",
and it was one of the funniest of the series.
Joe and Sal successfully get a "no" from their
customers.
“I put like thousands of mosquitos in his
house and I thought he’d like get the hint.
I mean do you think I deserved that?
"No.”
But Murr doesn't have the same luck, though
he does win $100 in a side bet from Joe after
caressing the chest hair of a customer.
The final participant is Q, but that's when
the entire prank goes awry and ends up creating
one of the best "Impractical Jokers" moments
of all time.
“Oh my god!
He threw it at the wrong guy!"
The actor quickly realizes his mistake but
maintains there's nothing he can do now.
Luckily, the aggrieved party is a good sport
about the whole thing and is able to laugh
it off.
You know the punishment is going to be good
in "Impractical Jokers" when it covers almost
half the episode.
And Murr's Judo bout during a poolside cocktail
party in the episode "The Party Crasher" is
one of these rare few.
For this punishment, Murr has to crash a cocktail
party and start a wrestling match with two-time
U.S. Olympic Gold Medalist Judo champion Kayla
Harrison.
Murr already looks incredibly conspicuous
wearing a wig made from Q's hair and his constant
flailing at Kayla quickly gets the attention
of all of the party guests.
And he’s only allowed to say one thing about
the situation.
“I know her from college.”
After she rips off his toupee during an ill-fated
takedown attempt, he has to put it back on
and continue wearing it, looking completely
disheveled.
At one point, Kayla throws Murr through a
table, and he just tries to play it off as
best he can.
For the finale, Kayla launches Murr over her
head into the pool after his final failed attack.
The guests clap and cheer for Kayla, who walks
back and enjoys the rest of the party.
Seeing Murr get manhandled by an Olympic Gold
Medalist was a highlight of the season and
one of the best celebrity cameos of the entire
series.
The episode "Blind Justice" features one of
Sal's best all-time punishments.
His task is to act as a hardened convict and
give a scared-straight speech to a room full
of teenagers.
He thinks the only catch is that he has to
wear a pair of sunglasses that 100% obscure
his view and use a few props.
However, the guys reveal to the audience the
true deviousness of the punishment: he is
in fact, not speaking to a crowd of teenagers.
"Shut up!
I don’t wanna hear anybody."
He lectures them about not disappointing their
parents and warns them about spending the
next 50 years of their life in prison.
The audience starts laughing at the ridiculous
speech.
Sal hears this but doesn't fully understand,
which just makes him yell more.
“You look nice and tight boy!
That’s what people are gonna tell you in
there."
Eventually, he puts two and two together.
“This is so not teens.
Take the glasses off.
Oh.”
And for the grand finale, Sal shows them his
Jaden Smith tattoo, which makes them all break
out in hysterics.
It's no secret to fans of the show that Murr
had a massive childhood crush on Danica McKellar,
an actress from one of his favorite childhood
shows "The Wonder Years."
For his punishment in the "The Blunder Years"
episode, Murr has to interview McKellar in
a hotel conference room.
While that sounds pretty desirable, Murr has
to do so while completely oiled up and wearing
a speedo.
The guys tell him he's going to enter a bodybuilding
contest, which gives them cover to douse him
with oil and put him in a speedo, but it was
all just a ruse.
“Behind the door is gonna be a celebrity
that is Murray’s childhood crush.”
During the interview, Murr is told what to
say.
“Truth or dare?
I’ll go first.
Truth.
I used to kiss a poster of you when I was
younger.”
And she is told to act as harshly as possible
with Murr and she delivers in spades.
“Finish this equation.
Me plus you equals.
"Really awkward.”
After thoroughly embarrassing himself by trying
to do squats and flex for her, Murr is mercifully
allowed to leave the room and McKellar alone.
As soon as he walks out, she bursts out laughing,
but Murr is probably scarred for life.
The pranks where the guys participate in panels
are definite staples on "Impractical Jokers."
One of Q's most hilarious was from "Brother
of the Sisterhood".
Q has to sit in on a panel of experts talking
about feminism, posing as the author of a
blog titled "Brother of the Sisterhood."
And of course, he must disagree with everything
the panelists say.
“I think Michelle Obama’s a fantastic
example.
Right.
But she wouldn’t be in the White House if
her husband hadn’t gotten there.”
The host is in on the joke, but no one else
is, least of all the audience members.
First, Q has to explain the difference between
"men's jobs" and "women's jobs.”
“Hey man.
You know I’m all for women’s rights.
I mean who isn’t, but I also want my car
to run well.”
Then he is forced to defend a quote from his
fictional blog where he claimed that women
becoming mothers turn "emotionally unstable
and irrational."
“These ladies, they’re going through a
lot.
You know."
"Great answer.”
After several minutes of excruciatingly uncomfortable
and cringeworthy banter, Q has to give his
closing remarks.
And they consist solely of him telling the
almost exclusively female audience that he
finds it amazing they can go all day without
playing with their breasts.
It is without a doubt one of Q's most embarrassing
and awkward punishments in the series.
"The Q-Pay" might be the best-known and longest-lasting
prank in "Impractical Jokers" history.
Murr's the loser in this episode and his punishment
is that he has to wear a wig.
It doesn't sound too bad until you realize
whose hair he's wearing: Q's.
The guys have Q cut off his shoulder-length
hair and make it into a wig for Murray.
“Oh my god."
"No!
No!"
"That hair is going on that head.”
The wig doesn't look half bad at first but
doesn't suit Murr at all.
To make matters worse, Murr has to get his
passport picture taken with the wig.
This is to contrast with Murr's driver's license,
which features him with a shaved head and
shaved eyebrows from an earlier punishment.
Murr claims the hair smells like:
“Whiskey and pot.”
Unfortunately for Murr, he can't just take
off the wig after a day; he has to keep it
on for the remainder of the season.
There are several more episodes in Season
6 after "The Q-Pay," and Murr's hair just
gets worse and worse as time goes on.
The fact that it keeps going throughout the
season makes it by far the best "Impractical
Jokers" prank in the series.
It's almost like multiple punishments in one,
as every episode with him wearing it is like
an extra prank.